the problem with this whole dopamine
thing in the context of relationship is
that early on
it's incredibly intoxicating to the
point where oftentimes people don't
realize that they're veering
so hard i get the friend that's super
excited about somebody and they'll tell
you this story she did this crazy thing
and they get kind of wide-eyed and like
that doesn't sound good he's like
excited about it this is his drug
uncertainty it's excitement follows a
very predictable pattern where in three
to six months it's him complaining that
she's crazy or that the relationship is
a mess or that the original thing you
love now you hate here's that i think
the takeaway if you sense too much
excitement in yourself or too much
anticipation of how great someone is be
very cautious about the extremes of
dopamine be very wary about the thing
that makes you feel incredible and i i
say this with some trepidation because i
myself you know love love right i love
love i love love
ugh falling in love love being in love